[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravi de vous retrouver à
la Une de Ça vous regarde ce soir
l'école est-elle encore à l'abri des
influences sous le choc d'avoir perdu
l'un des leurs les enseignants racontent
leur désarroi à l'approche de la rentrée
trop seuls pas assez fort mais comment
les protéger on s'interrogera dans notre
grand débat alors de l'hommage national
à Samuel Paty vous entendrez aussi
Edward Philippe l'ancien Premier
ministre a répondu aux questions des
députés de la commission d'enquête sur
la gestion de la crise sanitaire ce sera
dans la chronique de Thomas des Prés et
puis on parlera aussi du foot français
au bord de la faillite avec l'affaire
médias pro aujourd'hui le groupe
espagnol a tenté de rassurer la Ligue 1
il réclame une renégociation de son
contrat quel avenir pour le championnat
décryptage sur ce plateau voilà tous ces
sujets on va les discuter les décrypter
avec notre grand témoin il est
journaliste il vient de signer une série
de grands entretiens pour LCP sur le
thème du pouvoir à haut risque est avec
nous ce soir voilà vous savez vous savez
tout de suite notre grand débat
[Musique]
bonsoir Yves Thréard bonsoir merci
d'être notre grand témoin ce soir
journaliste directeur adjoint du Figaro
je le disais vous signez une belle série
de grands entretiens coup de cœur pour
LCP sur ses hommes politiques qui
tombent sous le coup des affaires le
pouvoir à haut risque qu'on enverra
quelques extrêmes et l'actualité ce soir
c'est évidemment cet hommage d'Emmanuel
Macron à Samuel Patis ce professeur
d'histoire sauvagement assassiné le
corps enseignant est sous le choc et on
va en parler ce soir Patrick etsal
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes député les
républicains du Bas-Rhin ancien recteur
de l'académie de Limoges ancien
conseiller éducation de François Fillon
lorsqu'il était à Matignon c'est bien ça
c'est bien ça vous connaissez donc bien
ces questions bonsoir bonsoir Mathieu
logo tétine merci d'être là on a envie
de vous entendre vous êtes le professeur
de ce plateau professeur
d'histoire-géographie et éducation
civique en Seine-Saint-Denis et cause
secrétaire du SNES FSU de Créteil le
député de la République en marche
va nous rejoindre dans quelques instants
et bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam
bonsoir
et qui va ouvrir ce débat avec son
billet d'actu les attentes à la laïcité
ce soir si j'ai bien compris tout de
suite
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris Stéphane
les enseignants sont plus en plus
exposés à la pression des islamistes et
donc la laïcité de plus en plus
contestée à l'école le phénomène n'est
pas nouveau évidemment mais il
semblerait que l'assassinat de Samuel
Paty est pris donner l'occasion de prise
de conscience en général en tout cas
c'est ce qui apparaissait ce matin dans
la presse je vous laisse découvrir les
unes du jour et ça c'est LE FIGARO donc
mon frère il sera là mais c'était pareil
donc à gauche avec libération on voit
que l'inquiétude des enseignants face à
laïcité fait la Une et préoccupe tout le
monde et pourtant vous le disiez le
phénomène n'est pas nouveau alors ça
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
que le phénomène n'est pas nouveau on
peut remonter quasiment 20 ans en
arrière en décembre 2003
euh la commission Stasi avait remis un
rapport au président Chirac justement
sur le respect de la laïcité à l'école
donc dans ce rapport qui avait été remis
en listait déjà euh les attaques contre
la laïcité donc il y avait la
contestation des cours d'histoire et de
sciences naturelles il y avait le fait
que certaines filles ne voulaient pas
participer au cours de sport avec des
certificats bidons le rapport disait
même que certains profs parce que
c'était des femmes se trouvait contester
dans leur classe donc je vous parle d'un
rapport qui a été remis quasiment 20 ans
donc et voilà ce qui est écrit en toutes
lettres dans le rapport de la main
d'ailleurs de Bernard Stasi il faut être
lucide oui des groupes extrémistes sont
à l'oeuvre dans notre pays pour tester
la résistance de la République et pour
pousser certains gènes à rejeter la
France et ses valeurs et apparemment
donc ça t'appelle à la laïcité n'a pas
été entendue à la lucidité non non pas
vraiment en tout cas pas sur le coup au
contraire le rapport à l'époque était
plutôt contesté notamment parce qu'il
préconisait l'interdiction du voile à
l'école donc à l'époque les principaux
syndicats
enseignants c'était d'ailleurs contesté
ce rapport vous allez pouvoir d'ailleurs
un article du Monde qui faisait le point
là-dessus en disant une majorité d'un
syndicat sont contre la loi sur le voile
parce que vous avez le sentiment que
cette loi aurait pour conséquence de
stigmatiser une partie de leurs élèves
en l'occurrence les élèves musulmans
évidemment à l'époque personne imaginait
qu'un professeur puisse être des
capitaux assassiné pour avoir montré les
caricatures des serviettes on
n'imaginait pas que ça pourrait un jour
arriver jusque là mais les menaces de
mort contre des professeurs là non plus
on parle pas du tout quelque chose de
récent pas simplement Al-Qaïda qui a
fait ses menaces là au procès Charlie il
y a déjà 5 ans condames je suis occupé
encore le territoire en Syrie et bien il
y avait des menaces de mort qui était
publiées dans leur média et voyez ils
s'en prenaient directement à l'école
française en disant menaçant de mort les
profs qui enseignaient la laïcité donc
on peut comprendre que du coup les
enseignants face à ce climat ou ce
changement de climat soit de plus en
plus prudent lorsqu'il s'agit d'aborder
des sujets qui risquent de déclencher la
colère des islamistes donc il y a eu un
sondages de l'Ifop qui remonte à mars
2018 donc c'était il y a déjà un an et
demi on a interrogé les enseignants donc
l'ensemble des enseignants 37% disent
que ce sont déjà auto censurés pour
éviter des problèmes mais quand on est
dans des zones d'éducation de
prioritaire donc dans les quartiers
sensibles c'est une majorité
d'enseignants qui préfèrent éditer
d'aborder certains sujets pour éviter
les problèmes qui vont avec donc face à
ce recul de laïcité forcément
Jean-Michel Blanquer a tenu à réagir et
donc son il a lancé un appel au prof
pour leur dire n'ayez pas peur la
République est là on l'écoute une des
choses que l'on doit combattre c'est la
peur n'oublions pas que ce que veulent
les terroristes par définition c'est la
terreur et donc chaque fois qu'on se
laisse gagner par la terreur et parfois
il y a matière et bien d'une certaine
façon on leur donne en partie raison
donc mon rôle c'est de conforter
l'institution derrière chacun de ces
acteurs pour que chacun se sente ne se
sente pas seul et sans que derrière il y
a toute la République et que donc la
République est inébranlable que ce sont
les enseignants qui se retrouvent en
première ligne de ce combat pour la
laïcité effectivement un combat à mener
contre l'islam RA c'était le sens du
discours du président de la République
et je vais vous laisser un petit sondage
pour finir avant de vous laisser
débattre ou pour vous dire que ce combat
contre l'islam radical ne fait que
commencer ou encore une fois le Figaro
je le cite mais qui lui-même si tu es un
sondage de l'iPhone qui disait que donc
3/4 des Français musulmans de moins de
25 ans disent que et ben ils mettent les
lois de l'islam au-dessus des lois de la
République donc plus ils sont jeunes
plus les Français musulmans mettent
l'islam au-dessus de la République donc
la question qu'on se pose c'est mais
combien d'années va encore durer ce
combat pour défendre la laïcité merci
Stéphane on va répondre à
il y a beaucoup de choses dans votre
papier ce soir je vais commencer par
vous Mathieu logo Téti depuis cette
assassinat Stéphane nous disait on la
parole c'est libérée on se rend compte
que l'autocensure elle existait bien
avant cette cette assassinat au dieu
est-ce que les enseignants ont peur
aujourd'hui on peut lire des mots dans
le Figaro dans Le Parisien on nous en
demande trop on ne veut pas être des
martyrs laïques on marche sur les
braises en permanence est-ce que les
enseignants ont peur
bon évidemment déjà ils ont été
abasourdi par cet acte parce que pour
nous votre collègue a rappelé les
menaces qu'on avait subi ces cinq
dernières années mais c'était de la
fiction nous allons nous menacer plein
de choses mais rien ne se passait là il
y a eu un événement qui a choqué tout le
monde qui nous a fait nous sentir en
insécurité alors est-ce qu'ils ont peur
bon témoignage dans l'Express je
pardonnez-moi de vous je pourrais
peut-être que il n'est que minoritaire
mais qui chamboule une jeune professeure
de français ou Seine-Saint-Denis apeuré
à l'idée de retourner en classe c'est le
2 novembre prochain et gêner aussi par
cette peur qu'il a longtemps conduit à
l'autocensure alors est-ce qu'ils ont
peur je ne sais pas en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'ils seront là le 2
novembre en classe face aux élèves et
que ils vont essayer de reprendre de
reprendre nos classes en abordant ce
fait d'une manière ou d'une autre alors
déjà en fonction de ce que nous
demandera le ministère puisque là on ne
sait pas encore exactement ce que ce que
le ministère va nous demander de faire
mais aussi en essayant d'utiliser cet
événement pour sortir de l'émotion et
pour amener de l'enseignement c'est à
dire des connaissances des faits sur ces
mouvements terroristes sur la manière
dont il fonctionne parce que ce qui
s'est passé autour de Samuel Paty c'est
un cas tout à fait exceptionnel d'une
manipulation qui est professeur ça vous
donne envie de dire j'y retourne tout de
suite je parle de la laïcité je monte
les caricatures je fais l'enseignement
de la liberté d'expression parce que je
faisais cours samedi matin donc j'ai vu
les élèves samedi matin
je suis passé les élèves nous en ont pas
parlé en fait tout simplement alors
peut-être qu'il était pas non plus
encore forcément très au courant ça sera
sûrement le cas à la rentrée non mais on
est c'est pas parce qu'on se pose des
questions c'est normal qu'on se pose des
questions on est des professionnels on
affronte des adolescents qui sont
toujours pro à nous remettre en question
dès qu'ils le peuvent ce qui est bien
normal
alors moi je ne dis pas à mes élèves
samedi matin parce que j'étais quand
même encore beaucoup dans l'émotion
depuis quand je pense comme tous les
collègues d'histoires géo qui enseignent
de l'EMC on y on y réfléchit parce qu'on
sait que lundi on va les revoir et qui
va en plus on va sûrement nous demander
de leur en parler donc il faut qu'on se
prépare
je précise bonsoir Gaëlle Le Boeck merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes député la
République en marche d'Ille-et-Vilaine
c'est sûr de Redon le port Atlantique le
plus proche de Paris c'est bien ça on
parlait à l'instant de la peur pas
forcément d'ailleurs on peut pas
généraliser
l'autocensure elle existait avant
l'autocensure on le voit les chiffres
disent que cette ensure elle existait la
question c'est comment comment on fait
bloc comment vous parler des enseignants
et de vos collègues et je vous félicite
parce qu'ils sont tous voilà pris par
cette question là et je crois que la
question c'est comment on les accompagne
pour faire bloc souvent je pense et
c'est certains chiffres aussi on a fait
une enquête cet été une grande
consultation des professeurs ils disent
que parfois ils sont pas bien
accompagnés de façon collective de façon
psychologique quand ils sont en
difficulté et la question c'est comment
on aide la communauté éducative et que
le prof se sente pas isolé dans ces cas
là formation on va y venir mais je
voudrais qu'on reste un peu sur l'état
d'esprit paroles d'enseignants c'est un
sujet de Nathalie guilloire et je vous
fais réagir juste après
la profession est combative surtout pas
céder à la peur les professeurs font de
la résistance ils ont décidé de ne rien
lâcher et sont d'attaque pour la rentrée
ils le font savoir notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux je suis prof
d'histoire-géo tous les jours j'ai du
kalaïcité à la liberté de conscience à
la liberté d'expression jamais je ne
cesserai de le faire non à la barbarie
aujourd'hui je voudrais être à l'école
pour écouter les élèves pour parler pour
en parler avec eux et passons-nous les
professeurs lancent un cri d'espoir sur
Twitter avec le hashtag je suis prof je
suis enseignant mais le retour à la
réalité n'est jamais très loin les
enseignants expriment aussi leurs
inquiétudes ça fait partie de notre
travail
d'en parler de
de travailler sur le principe de laïcité
et d'essayer de faire passer des
messages et que c'est extrêmement
extrêmement compliqué on le sait et on
le vit au quotidien et sur les réseaux
ils n'hésitent pas à interpeller les
politiques comme ce professeur qui
répond ministre de l'éducation nationale
nous ferons face facile à dire dans
votre tour d'ivoire pendant que nous
sommes sur le terrain à subir sans être
ni moyen nous attendons des vrais actes
pas juste du blabla sinon pas de rentrer
une autre critique revient également
celle de la responsabilité des parents
d'élèves Madame M qui affiché
aujourd'hui
# je suis enseignant pensez-y demain
quand vous contesterez la dernière note
de Kevin la punition parce qu'il
refusait d'enlever sa casquette ou parce
qu'il a frappé un élève qu'il avait bien
cherché soyez enseignants
quotidiennement les messages des
professeurs se multiplient ils seront
nombreux à vivre une rentrée
particulière au retour des vacances de
la Toussaint il frayard est-ce qu'on
assiste à un réveil est-ce qu'on assiste
à la fin d'une forme de déni sujet
notamment dans le corps les réactions
qu'on entend aujourd'hui il y a 5 ans je
pense qu'on aurait pas pu les formuler
même parce qu'on aurait été tout de
suite taxé
d'islamophobe
d'amalgamistes donc aujourd'hui je
dirais que l'appareil la parole se
libère ça c'est la première des choses
la deuxième des choses c'est que les
Français prennent conscience quel que
soit leur confessions leurs origines
prennent conscience que le l'islamisme
que l'on dénonce c'est un projet
politique c'est pas uniquement un
dévoiement de la religion c'est un
projet politique qui s'immense qui se
diffuse dans tous les replis de la
société et qui veut justement détruire
notre culture notre civilisation et
c'est très symbolique que là ça soit
l'école qui soit en cause le collège le
lycée l'enseignement parce que justement
c'est là où on forme les esprits de nos
pays c'est là où on forme les
intelligences et là si vous voulez il y
a je pense qu'il y a on dépasse
l'émotion et les Français se disent pour
beaucoup d'entre eux il faut réagir
parce que il faut nous préserver nous
défendre sinon on va être
grignoté on va être mangé et il faut pas
se leurrer
l'islamisme veut installer un califat en
France c'est pas uniquement de l'autre
côté de la Méditerranée ils veulent
prendre le pouvoir c'est un projet
politique
on entendait les les enseignants on sent
que voilà ils ont été extrêmement
secoués mais ils sont pas tous résignés
je précise parce que voilà ils ont envie
d'aller enseigner faire leur métier ils
n'ont pas tous complètement tétanisés
parce qu'il s'est passé vous qui avez
été recteur c'est remonté de terrain
c'était quoi pourquoi on n'arrive pas à
dire les choses on peut lire aujourd'hui
que une professeure une maîtresse de CM1
qui fait une leçon de vocabulaire sur
les animaux avec un projet d'avoir
utiliser le mot cochon
comment c'est possible que ça ne remonte
pas que ça ne soit pas dit qu'il n'y ait
pas au fond les outils républicains pour
riposter en fait moi je voudrais vous
vous y faites référence les enseignants
jouent un rôle ils sont en première
ligne il faut leur rendre hommage le
métier est devenu de plus en plus
difficile et en fait ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
l'appareil le disait à l'instant la
parole est en train de se libérer ils
sont en première ligne ils ont envie de
faire face mais ce dont ils ont besoin
ce sont deux choses d'abord il faut que
cesse quelque chose qui s'est installé
dans le système de de cette maison
éducation nationale qui est le pas de
vagues ça il faut que ça c'est ça il
faut vraiment le dire et je crois que
nous devons alors là vous étiez dans
l'institution alors à l'époque moi
j'étais recteur donc il y a une
quinzaine d'années la question se posait
il faut le dire de manière assez
différente et les choses se sont
accentuées au cours des dernières années
et quand je dis au cours des dernières
années on l'a vu
au moment des attentats de Charlie la
minute de silence qui a certains
endroits n'a pas été respecté je crois
que là nous aurions déjà dû réagir de
manière plus active et là on nous a dit
pas de vagues et le la deuxième chose
c'est d'institutions
non pas les professeurs pas enfin
peut-être certains mais en fait le et
c'est le deuxième point sur lequel je
voudrais insister ce sont les corps
intermédiaires ce sont les chefs
d'établissement les inspecteurs il ne
s'agit pas de les pointer du doigt mais
en réalité ils doivent être en soutien
et effectivement on le voit aujourd'hui
il y a des inspecteurs il y a des chefs
d'établissement qui étaient dans une
logique où il disait surtout ne faisons
pas remonter parce que nous sommes
évalués par notre hiérarchie et si nous
sommes mal évalués et bien savoir avoir
des conséquences négatives sur notre
propre carrière et je pense que ce sont
ces deux points sur lesquels il va
falloir retravailler et c'est là où nous
attendons maintenant Jean-Michel
Blanquer et quand des enseignants disent
il faut passer des paroles aux actes
c'est vrai que plus que jamais nous
devons passer
autocensure ou même du système qui vous
plaît voilà on va pas on va pas en
parler ça va compliquer les choses vous
l'avez vous l'avez vécu je sais pas je
crois déjà que les élèves qui seraient
éventuellement radicalisés ne se
manifeste pas forcément c'est pas
forcément des élèves qui vont en classe
allez dire au professeur qu'il ne sont
pas d'accord ou qu'ils ne croient pas à
ce que nous sommes en train de raconter
vous personnellement vous n'avez jamais
été confronté à ce genre de situation
donc je peux pas non plus dire que ce
soit une seule fois une seule fois c'est
rien mais vous pouvez nous raconter que
la Shoah n'avait pas existé qu'à essayer
de me le démontrer mais c'était une
discussion on voyait qu'elle était un
peu enfin qu'elle avait un fond derrière
donc elle avait dû être formée par
quelqu'un bon après c'est un échange
tout à fait courtois bon je ne suis pas
sûr de l'avoir convaincu mais au moins
elle m'a écouté après ce genre de
[Musique]
on en parle avec les élèves quand ce
genre de choses arrivent et on est des
professionnels les enseignants enfin moi
je veux pas avant de parler du soutien
qu'on pourrait nous apporter déjà dire
que les enseignants ont une formation là
la laïcité c'est quelque chose que en
histoire-géographie par exemple on
apprend avant d'être en classe donc on a
des arguments on a des moyens on a des
connaissances qui nous permettent de
répondre à ce que les élèves peuvent
nous dire un mail par exemple au
ministère déjà on peut informer notre
hiérarchie localement il y a des chefs
d'établissement alors après je ne peux
pas l'Empire leur demander tout porter
parce qu'ils sont enfin dans un
établissement comme le mien un lycée de
1400 élèves il y a un chef
d'établissement et un adjoint donc il
fait ce qui peut mais lui il peut
remonter où elle peut remonter à la
hiérarchie c'est vraiment il y a un cas
grave qui doit être signé qu'est-ce qui
se passe pas très Cassel vous avez vous
avez ça redescend vous avez un
interlocuteur normalement dans dans une
dans un bon fonctionnement si les choses
remontent ça doit avoir des des
conséquences d'abord au niveau de
l'inspection académique dans les grandes
académies où éventuellement au niveau du
rectorat et là en fait il est essentiel
que les équipes soient soit davantage
formé on voit bien que
aujourd'hui ce que nous constatons le
maillon faible il est là aujourd'hui il
est là dans cette hiérarchie
intermédiaire parce que en fait quand
les professeurs qui sont en première
ligne à un moment donné se disent mais
finalement s'il y a un problème on va
être lâché par nos tir Archie et
d'ailleurs parfois avec des inspecteurs
j'ai entendu des formules on les entend
souvent fait au mieux mais le fait au
mieux c'est débrouillez-vous et je crois
que c'est ça que nous devons là aussi
revoir et ça ne peut pas se faire
l'enseignant seul effectivement vous
avez parfaitement raison il a il est en
première ligne mais il faut aussi que le
collectif fonctionne on en demande trop
au professeur qu'est-ce qu'on fait
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire je crois que
Corinne il y a une responsabilité
politique
et cette responsabilité politique elle
est portée principalement par le
ministre de l'Éducation le ministre de
l'Éducation actuelle on peut pas lui
faire de procès parce que là-dessus il a
un discours on ne peut plus clair
c'était quelqu'un qui a toujours défendu
la laïcité on se rappelle de ses propos
sur le voile sur la voie publique où il
disait c'était pas souhaitable donc il
va suspect en revanche il y a beaucoup
d'hommes et de femmes politiques qui
occupaient le ministère de l'Éducation
et qui n'ont pas je dirais une attitude
ferme on va prendre un exemple le
rapport au bain monsieur Aubin c'est un
inspecteur de l'Éducation nationale qui
a fait un rapport sur justement toutes
les atteintes à la laïcité dans les dans
l'éducation nationale en 2004 ce rapport
il a été rangé mis sous le tapis sous
prétexte dixit le ministre de
l'Éducation de l'époque qui était
monsieur Fillon sous prétexte que ce
rapport intervenait juste après la loi
de 2004 sur le port du voile dans les
écoles et que ça allait
automatisé encore davantage les élèves
musulmans c'est la deuxième raison c'est
que ça pourrait fâcher nos et corner nos
relations diplomatiques avec le Maroc la
Tunisie l'Algérie donc on voit que s'il
y a une volonté politique et c'est vrai
dans l'éducation nationale c'est vrai
dans les services publics c'est vrai à
l'hôpital c'est vrai partout si le
discours politique et ferme et bien je
pense que ceux qui sont sur le terrain
se sentent davantage soutenus et porté
pour faire respecter cette laïcité
non moi il y a quelque chose que je
rejoins beaucoup c'est comment on
regarde et comment on transforme cette
organisation moi j'attends pas tout du
ministre c'est-à-dire que on a vu ça on
a fait une grande consultation on a fait
une grande consultation cet été on voit
des profs écartelés entre un engagement
énorme un sens au travail voir les
enfants progresser et de l'autre
être vraiment à pas avoir les moyens la
formation comment le soutien
psychologique donc on voit des
enseignants qui sont écartelés avec
moins de 15% satisfaction d'un côté sur
plein de points et plus de 80% sur un
autre point qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que entre les deux on
parlait des corps intermédiaires mais
pas que c'est pour ça que j'attends pas
tout humide le ministre évidemment qu'il
a il a fait évidemment qu'il doit y
aller mais il doit aussi
n'était pas un peu ambiguë avec des
propos fermes si vous n'avez pas
l'organisation qui suit derrière c'est
pas tout de libérer la parole moi je
veux que on libère l'écoute de
l'organisation et comment on fait en
sorte que les corps intermédiaires dont
vous parlez soit à cette écoute là
comment il puisse organiser comment
quand est-ce que c'est un mail institut
comment on crée des cours de moyens
voilà plus d'outils plus de moyens pour
accompagner soutenir les profs on sait
qu'il y a des signes également possible
mais ça ne suffit pas il faut renforcer
surtout dans l'organisation des moyens
des corps intermédiaires en plus c'est
comment on remonte plus facilement ces
choses là quand on entend à certains
États généraux que
des pédagogies nouvelles ou comment on
transforme aussi ces pédagogies comment
on permet la liberté comment permet
l'innovation parce que sans souvent les
professeurs ils se sentent voilà je le
disais tout à l'heure embarqué juste
dans un point il faut qu'on veut les
laisser il faut évidemment un langage
manuit sans dire on fait un Grenelle et
sentez-vous à l'aise de proposer des
nouvelles organisations sentez-vous à
l'aise de remonter les choses et nous
allons vous écouter Matthieu le gotetti
doit ressembler le 2 novembre le jour de
la rentrée vous avez entendu le ministre
il y aura une minute de silence ça déjà
est-ce que vous approuvez
alors la minute de silence c'est
intéressant dans le sens où ça peut nous
permettre de discuter avec les élèves
souvent alors on a beaucoup parlé on des
attentats de Charlie par exemple des
élèves qui refusaient de faire la minute
de silence nous ce qu'on a constaté
c'était pas tous des islamistes du tout
mais les adolescents sont des
adolescents et quand on leur demande de
faire quelque chose certains résistent
de fait et à ce moment-là ça peut
permettre d'avoir une discussion la mine
de s'élance c'est l'émotion c'est le
fait d'exprimer c'est aussi un outil
pédagogique après voilà il faut
l'utiliser comme tel si on nous dit
simplement en fait une minute sinon
c'est après passer à autre chose là
c'était assez
différente
refusent cette minute qu'est-ce qu'on
fait et ben on rentre dans la pédagogie
on rentre dans la discussion moi
monsieur disait que les enseignants
membres de formation je sais pas si
c'est un problème de formation on est
formé et on a tous un bagage qui fait
qu'on est des professionnels on enseigne
tous enfin certains depuis assez
longtemps Seine-Saint-Denis par exemple
on est capable d'affronter Jean de
situations
alors est-ce que est-ce que vous vous
voulez les montrer est-ce que vous
attendez ce qu'on vous dise quoi faire
avec ces
caricatures qui quelque part un peu
rentre dans notre histoire aujourd'hui
là je crois que c'est la liberté de
chaque enseignant de dire est-ce que
dans ce que je suis en train de faire en
ce moment montrer cette caricature ou
celle-là à un sens pédagogique pour les
élèves je crois que le but c'est pas
forcément de choquer choquer les élèves
ça sert à quoi l'important c'est de les
amener à réfléchir et de leur permettre
de construire des notions
on peut parler la liberté expression
d'expliquer ce que c'est par exemple le
droit de blasphème dans notre République
sans forcément montrer ces images là
Gaëlle
a cette liberté pédagogique de montrer
ce qu'il a envie de montrer pour
construire les compétences qu'il a envie
de construire avec ses élèves ce qui est
pas admissible et là où je vous rejoins
et il faut la fermeté c'est que
aucun enseignant ne doit avoir peur par
contre de les montrer s'il estime qu'il
doit les montrer à partir du moment où
il dit moi j'ai envie de les montrer
pour construire quelque chose avec les
élèves il doit être à l'aise il doit pas
avoir peur il doit pas refuser et là il
doit y avoir un bloc mais dans le
contexte actuel et c'est pour ça que je
pense que la minute est importante qu'on
y aille tous qu'on soit tous présents le
ministreur nous a invité à tous avoir
notre rôle dans cette reprise là pour
faire bloc pour être là avec les
enseignants c'est le message aussi
global de la société quand on disait
tout à l'heure c'est les corps
intermédiaires c'est le ministre c'est
nous tous c'est les journalistes sont
les députés sont les éditorialistes
en l'occurrence ce professeur
Samuel Paty quand il a décidé de montrer
ses caricatures il a fait le choix de
demander aux élèves qui pourraient être
heurtés par ces images de sortir de la
classe alors apparemment c'est parce
qu'il a fait c'est parce qu'il a fait
attention il a dit si vous êtes si cela
vous dérange détournez le regard
justement il n'a pas demandé de sortir
ça le l'enquête la dose est déjà montré
il a dit à tout le monde tout à fait
tout à fait il l'a dit à tout le monde
exactement je crois que c'est important
de le dire
en mémoire de de cette enseignant qui
qui a laissé ça c'est quand même un
collègue qui avait 25 ans d'expérience
il était il était reconnu dans son
académie il était en institut du Monde
Arabe a fait un communiqué pour rappeler
qu'il était en référent culturel de son
académie sur Versailles donc c'est un
professionnel qui maîtrisait ce qu'il
faisait alors les polémiques autour
parce que il y a eu effectivement des
polémique sur le rôle du principe sur le
fait que le père de d'élèves de Samuel
Patier était au fond convoqué ou en tous
les cas il y a une médiation pour le
rencontrer avec avec le conseil
de l'enquête donc je peux pas me
prononcer là-dessus la situation
nationale a essayé quand même de faire
quelque chose Samuel Paty il a été aussi
victime moi ce qu'on ressent des
articles que vous publiez il a été
victime d'une manipulation par des gens
qui en fait n'avaient pas tellement
grand chose à voir avec le collège mais
est-ce que le fait sur la liberté
d'expression et sur ces sujets sensibles
si c'est au programme les élèves doivent
rester dans la classe
leur a dit pour pas pour ceux qui
avaient le droit d'exprimer le fait
qu'ils étaient choqués par une
caricature
qu'ils avaient le droit de détourner le
regard moi je vois pas en quoi ça c'est
choquant
que le professeur
et ça montre justement probablement que
c'était un très bon pédagogue pour dire
une image qui vous heurte détourner le
regard mais évidemment enfin je
comprends ce professeur là à la
télévision tous les jours
moins de 13 ans et les parents
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les parents
après après cette assassinat est-ce
qu'on les embarque où est-ce qu'ils
doivent rester à la porte de l'école les
parents ont leur rôle à jouer je crois
qu'on ne va pas on ne va pas pouvoir du
jour au lendemain dire aux parents vous
restez à l'extérieur par contre vous
voyez là où vous évoquez tout à l'heure
une manipulation ce qui a été
extrêmement choquant et nous l'avons
tous noté c'est l'arrivée à un moment
donné d'un imam dans l'établissement
alors qu'il n'avait rien à y faire
autoproclamé de surcroît là il y a eu
quelque chose de terrible et je crois
que nous devons là être ferme vous
disiez tout à l'heure le ministre doit
être ferme et l'ensemble de la
hiérarchie doit être ferme la fermeté ça
sera essentiel dans les dans les
prochains temps vous voyez lorsque
Samuel Paty est allé porter plainte
parce qu'il était dit famille parce
qu'il était attaqué et bien la
principale l'accompagner mais je pense
que l'étape d'après il faudra le faire
de manière systématique parce que là ça
n'a pas été fait il faut que l'État
porte plainte parce que c'est un
fonctionnaire dans l'exercice de sa
mission de fonctionnaire qui a été
diffamé et à partir de là c'est l'État
qui est dit fin mais l'État est en
diffamé il doit lui-même porter plainte
et là je pense que ce message de fermeté
il doit être clair et je crois qu'il ne
faut plus transiger avec cela et il faut
accorder dès le départ là aussi la
protection fonctionnelle au
fonctionnaire qui se retrouve dans cette
situation pour qu'il se rende compte que
l'institution est vraiment avec eux et
sera bienveillante avec eux y compris
lorsqu'ils ont pu et ça peut arriver
aussi faire une erreur à un moment donné
mais que dès le départ il soit parce que
en fait le problème du pas de vague
c'est que certains hésitent en disant
oulala mais qu'est-ce qui peut m'arriver
est-ce que mon institution me suivra il
ne faut plus qu'un enseignant doute de
la volonté de son institution à le
soutenir dans son action pédagogique
il y a beaucoup de choses à voir dans
nos réflexes et dans notre comportement
vis-à-vis de de encore une fois de ce
projet politique qui veut notre
destruction faut pas se faut pas se
leurrer donc il faut aussi
restaurer l'autorité dans les à l'école
et que cette autorité elle soit assumée
parce que on dit que ce dont a souffert
Samuel Paty c'est que
c'est maintenant beaucoup les parents
d'élèves qui font la loi dans les écoles
je ne suis pas enseignant le gros des
atteintes à la laïcité ce sont les
parents derrière beaucoup de parents qui
poussent et qui ont eux aussi
participent à ce projet mortifère que
celui de l'islamisme mais
au-delà de ça c'est l'autorité en
général qui est beaucoup moins respectée
que du temps des hussards noirs de la
République dont on chantait louanges
alors Mathieu le gotettis sur la place
des parents sur leur rôle au fond quand
on sent bien qu'à la maison on vient
contester le discours du professeur
l'école sont les parents ça me semble
impossible enfin ça c'est clair les
parents ont leur place dans l'école je
pense aussi qu'on est dans une société
où grâce aux réseaux sociaux les parents
la liberté d'expression d'ailleurs tout
le monde sur les professeurs qu'il n'y
avait pas avant vous parler d'une serre
noir à l'époque du serveur on pouvait
pas dire qu'on en pensait dans les
médias maintenant maintenant ce qui est
important c'est que les parents ils ont
leur place ils participent à l'éducation
évidemment puisque ce sont leurs enfants
que nous avons mais les cours que nous
faisons là ce sont des professionnels
qui participent alors si un parent a une
question évidemment il peut les poser il
est il peut venir recontrer les
professeurs ils peuvent venir rencontrer
la hiérarchie c'est tout à fait possible
après si on repère des des gens qui sont
justement radicalisés là je crois que
c'est en fait dans le contenu
pédagogique les certificats médicaux de
complaisance les allergies aux chlore
pour ne pas aller à la piscine par
exemple
ça existe
oui ça existe ça existe alors après bah
ça c'est à l'éducation nationale de
signaler et puis il y a d'autres
services de public que ce soit la
justice la police qui doivent rentrer en
jeu aussi là quand l'affaire de Samuel
paddie bon je sais pas ce que donnera
l'enquête mais ce qui s'est ce qui s'est
passé c'est qu'il a été menacé quand
même sur sur des réseaux sociaux publics
on n'était pas dans le cadre du collège
a priori dans le collège la situation
quand même semblait régler plus ou moins
donc c'est venu de l'extérieur et c'est
là-dessus qu'il aurait fallu agir moi je
veux pas savoir qui n'a pas agi je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas il faudrait il
faudrait qu'on le détermine je voudrais
qu'on détermine ce débat par une
dernière question un dernier tour de
table sur le lien avec Jean-Michel
Blanquer parce que le corps enseignant
et Jean-Michel Blanquer ont eu maille à
partir sur plusieurs réformes c'est pas
vous qui allez me contredire est-ce que
est-ce qu'une unité une forme de
réconciliation est possible d'après ce
qui s'est passé parce qu'il va falloir
que voilà les choses se fassent de façon
de façon collective ça peut pas être
autrement je pense qu'elle est
souhaitable je sais pas si ça va être
possible mais je pense qu'elle est
souhaitable je pense que là le corps
enseignant je peux pas parler à sa place
mais quand même commencé extrêmement
fra extrêmement choqué extrêmement
j'espère pas trop atteint justement par
la crainte parce que ça serait ça serait
pire que tout ça voudrait dire que
justement le pas de vagues gagnerait
finalement mais on peut considérer que
les professeurs bah faut se mettre à
leur place ils sont en première ligne et
avec ce qui s'est passé c'est pas simple
mais il faut effectivement que il y ait
ce qui n'empêche pas le débat il faut
pas non plus dire bon bah il y a plus de
débat sur la réforme du baccalauréat sur
la réforme de l'école au contraire mais
il faut vraiment que l'ail et une unité
sur les valeurs de la République parce
que c'est elle qui sont en jeu
ici est-ce que voilà il y a un contrat
avec votre Ministre sur la popularité de
Jean-Michel Blanquer parmi les
enseignants qui en effet montre que
c'est très négatif moi je crois que le
ministre peut déjà aussi prendre
l'habitude d'écouter aussi les
représentants des personnels nous par
exemple on lui avait demandé des moyens
importants concernant le covid on a eu
aucune réponse aujourd'hui les
établissements fonctionnent comme si de
rien n'était alors si là il y a des
moyens humains à mettre dans cette
situation bah pourquoi pas nous avons
des propositions et il va falloir coudre
ce fil du dialogue on l'entend merci
beaucoup d'être venu sur le plateau
delceppé par les de ces de ces questions
on va parler un peu de vous à présent
istresart et de votre actualité sur
notre chaîne vous signez je le disais
une série de grandes entretiens sur au
fond le thème de la chute en politique
[Musique]
alors 3 trois hommes on va montrer trois
extraits Loïc Le Floch Prigent Michel
Noir Alain Carignon pourquoi les avoir
choisi eux quel était votre projet avec
ces grands entretiens le projet de ces
entretiens et grâce d'ailleurs à toute
l'équipe de la Chaîne parlementaire il
faut le dire Assemblée nationale
Ghislaine Chenu Bertrand delay
évidemment son président c'était je leur
ai proposé un sujet sur le pouvoir à
haut risque exercer le pouvoir ça peut
comporter et ça comporte des risques
alors
ceux que j'ai sélectionné pour
participer à mes entretiens ce sont des
gens qui ont connu des ascension souvent
fulgurante dans le monde de l'industrie
dans le monde politique principalement
mais qui à un moment et ben ont chuté on
fait la une de l'actualité ont vu leur
réputation
salie ternie et non pas parce que ils
avaient rien fait certains d'entre eux
avaient fait avaient commis des
grâces
et ça c'est ce que je voulais savoir
c'est comment on vit ça alors première
extrait Loïc lefeuch Prigent qui va très
loin au fond et qui explique on se
souvient de l'affaire elfe que parfois
la fin justifie les moyens
quand on est capitaine d'industrie comme
vous l'avez été est-ce que la fin
justifie tous les moyens non pas tous
les moyens mais beaucoup de moyens les
cas à dire que notre notre souci quand
l'industrie c'est de faire marcher
l'entreprise et faire votre entreprise
bien ça nécessite de faire un certain
nombre de choses qui sont pas forcément
morales pas forcément morale
c'est-à-dire c'est à dire que lorsque on
considère que il faut absolument
réaliser une opération on est on est sur
le fil de la bonne morale classique
est-ce que vous calculez la part du
risque entre ce qui est moral et immoral
non non
essentiellement vous gagnez pas à tout
prix encore une fois jusqu'à un certain
point c'est à dire que quand il y a des
mords possibles bien évidemment là fini
il se trouve que Eva Joly appartenait à
la famille de Loïc le flop Prigent c'est
à dire que eva jolie quand elle est
arrivée de Scandinavie comme jeune fille
au père en France elle a elle était dans
une famille d'accueil et elle a épousé
le fils de cette famille d'accueil il se
trouve que cette famille d'accueil sont
des lointains est une en cousinage
lointain avec le flop présent donc c'est
incroyable c'est-à-dire que la personne
qui qui l'a vraiment harcelé on peut le
dire comme ça et bien c'était quelqu'un
qui est pas appartenait à sa famille
allez on passe à Michel Noir
expliquez-nous pourquoi lui pourquoi ce
choix alors Michel Noir alors là c'est
typique là on est en politique c'est
quelqu'un qui a très vite monté à tel
point et c'est le début de l'entretien à
tel point que il se croyait un jour
président de la République quand je lui
pose la question il dit oui tout le
monde me le disait que j'allais devenir
président de la République on est à la
fin des années
entre les années 85 et 95 et il est
grand il est beau c'est un beau mec il
est devenu maire de Lyon il rafler tous
les arrondissements il a été cinq fois
élu député de suite et puis il avait un
gendre alors ça c'est une affaire de
famille on appelait ça
l'affaire de comment dynastie Rhône
dynastie
Rhône-Alpes parce que c'est une affaire
de famille et son gendre la fiche chuté
son genre a placé de l'argent en Suisse
de l'argent obtenu de façon pas très pas
du tout réglementaire et légal et ben ça
a coûté la carrière de Michel voilà et
Michel parce que il y a évidemment le
récit de cette disgrâce je le disais
mais il y a aussi des éléments beaucoup
plus personnels écoutez il y a quelque
chose qui vous a marqué
qu'on vous a collé comme étiquette c'est
que vous vouliez incarner la droite
morale pourquoi parce qu'il y a eu cette
tribune dans Le Monde en 1987 15 mieux
vaut perdre une élection que de perdre
son âme ça ça vous a collé à la peau
quand même mais ça c'est profondément ce
que je suis parce que moi je suis né à
Mathausen si je puis dire entre
guillemets c'est à dire que moi je
n'aime mon père résistant et déporté à
Mathausen il va me découvrir un an après
ma naissance et et
mon père m'a toujours dit n'oublie
jamais Mathausen c'est ce que ça
signifie
ce drame humain est de des sociétés de
l'humanité qui consiste à refuser
l'autre dans les pires formes
comme disait Socrate un Platon c'est à
dire que on essaye de faire parler
l'autre et là c'est vrai que moi je le
savais pas d'ailleurs avant d'entrer
dans cette entretien et pourtant j'ai
bossé mais mes interlocuteurs et j'avais
oublié j'avais un enfant de Mathausen
parce que fréquentes avec le Front
national le temps au fil Alain Carignon
qui raconte alors ça c'est incroyable
cette comment dire période de sa vie
écoutez
24 gardiens assure la surveillance et la
sécurité du criminel de guerre cette
cellule de Klaus Barbie criminel de
guerre vous allez l'occuper
qu'est-ce que vous êtes dire à ce
moment-là vous saviez que c'était la
série de Barbie
mais c'est sûr que le gardien qui a fait
un témoignage très hostile à ma personne
après après mon départ en disant que
j'étais pas du tout sympathique
[Musique]
le site
LCP.fr vous restez avec nous ytreart
savez-vous qu'Edouard philippe était
dans ses murs à l'Assemblée aujourd'hui
c'est Thomas Després qui va nous
raconter tout cela Thomas qui a suivi au
fond cette audition un peu particulière
n'est-ce pas Thomas oui exactement
madame Édouard Philippe l'ancien Premier
ministre il était auditionné cet
après-midi par les députés membres de la
commission d'enquête sur le coronavirus
je vous raconte tout ça
alors c'était l'événement de la journée
cet après-midi à l'Assemblée ce n'est
pas tous les jours qu'un ancien Premier
ministre vient à s'exprimer devant les
députés au Palais Bourbon Édouard
Philippe est arrivé peu avant 14h à pied
on a essayé de lui poser une question
mais il nous a pas répondu bonjour
monsieur le Premier ministre
qu'est-ce que vous allez venir dire au
député une fois qu'il était installé
devant la commission Édouard Philippe a
rendu des comptes sur sa gestion de
l'épidémie pendant la première vague dès
le 2 janvier nous avons engagé la veille
épidémiologique très tôt très tôt nous
avons mis en place le Stade 2 du chorus
nous n'avons pas attendu mars pour créer
la cellule intermittariale de crise pour
armer la cellule interministériale
est-ce que si nous avions eu beaucoup de
masques et beaucoup de tests en février
est-ce que on aurait pu éviter le
confinement complet je ne sais pas et la
vérité c'est que quand vous êtes
confronté à la gestion de crise vous
raisonnez pas comme ça
moi quand on m'a jamais parlé entre le
15 mai 2017 date où j'étais nommé
Premier ministre et
l'ami janvier 2020 je n'ai jamais
entendu parler de masque donc comment
est-ce qu'on gère une crise paie une
crise
sanitaire avec des échelons décision qui
sont très dispersés
aérs ministère responsable politique
fonctionnaire comment est-ce que vous la
prenez comment est-ce que vous la gérez
quand vous avez immédiatement
immédiatement le risque pénal sur le dos
si vous voulez faire en sorte que les
échelons administratifs ou politiques
soient moins réactif
faites en sorte que chaque élément de
décision ou de jour passer il y a un
risque pénal associé bonjour Julien
borrowitz vous êtes le président de
cette mission d'information qui s'est
dotée des pouvoirs d'une commission
d'enquête quel bilan vous vous tirez de
l'audition de l'ancien Premier ministre
et bien écoutez d'abord une audition où
on a eu un Premier ministre qui a su
répondre à toutes les questions
calmement posément modestement en
reconnaissant que parfois il ne savait
pas parce que le virus a évolué la
connaissance du virus a évolué et donc
qui a pris le temps de nous répondre
précisément à toutes les questions et
elles ont été nombreuses qui ont été
posées il y a eu quelques quelques
imprécisions voilà je prends le sujet
des stocks stratégiques des masques bon
le Premier ministre nous dit que jamais
cette question n'est remontée à son
niveau c'est ce que nous a dit également
la ministre de la santé c'est même ce
que nous a dit hier soir le conseiller
de la ministre de la Santé donc voilà je
reste très étonné que sur une question
aussi centrale si stratégique on nous
dise on n'a jamais regardé voilà Myriam
demain c'est l'ancien ministre de
l'Intérieur Christophe Castaner redevenu
député la République en marche qui
viendra s'exprimer devant les membres de
la commission d'enquête sur le
coronavirus merci Thomas vous aimez le
foot français vous êtes prêt à payer
pour le regarder à la télé j'adore le
foot alors l'avenir du foot est en péril
on en parle tout de suite avec nos
invités
[Musique]
bonsoir Virgil Caillet bonsoir merci
d'être là vous êtes délégué général de
l'Union sport et cycle c'est en quelque
sorte le Medef du sport si je ne dis pas
de bêtises
du sport et bienvenue à vous Cédric
Roussel vous êtes député la République
en marche des Alpes-Maritimes un grand
fan de foot mais un député qui veut
aussi mettre son nez dans ce qui est en
train de se passer je vous donne la
parole dans un instant parce que si vous
n'y comprenez rien comme moi à ce qui
est en train de se tramer dans le foot
français trois clés pour comprendre
c'est signer Julien Gall
[Musique]
qui diffuse les matchs de Ligue 1 Canal+
diffuseur historique conserve encore
quelques affiches mais huit rencontres
sur 10 de Ligue 1 et de Ligue 2 sont
diffusés par la nouvelle chaîne Téléfoot
créée pour l'occasion et propriété du
groupe de médias sino-espagnol média pro
pour obtenir ses droits ce nouvel
entrant a versé 814 millions d'euros par
an à la Ligue de Football Professionnel
la chaîne Téléfoot revendique 600 000
abonnés après quatre mois d'existence
très en dessous de l'objectif de 3
millions et demi censés assurer
l'équilibre
confronté à des difficultés financières
médias Pro a refusé de payer en octobre
sa mensualité de 172 millions d'euros de
traite dues au club français position
qui a suscité la colère des dirigeants
des clubs de football comme le patron de
l'OL Jean-Michel Aulas je vois pas quel
intérêt aurait
médias pro à ne pas payer parce qu'ils
se mettrait en situation juridique
extrêmement fragile mais pourquoi Media
Pro refusent-ils de payer le groupe
espagnol exige un rabais il estime que
la crise sanitaire a bouleversé la donne
match à huis clos moins attractifs et
rentrée publicitaire en baisse voilà
pourquoi ce matin lors d'une conférence
de presse le patron Jones rourd annonce
vouloir continuer la diffusion tout en
évoquant une renégociation du contrat
avec la Ligue nous allons respecter les
contrats et on va parler avec la Ligue
et sur les gens concernés ce soir les
gouvernements c'est soit les autorités
sportives c'est souvent n'importe qui
dans l'urgence la Ligue a emprunté 112
millions d'euros pour pouvoir financer
les clubs si média Pro ne peut plus
payer que devient alors la Ligue 1 déjà
privée de recettes de billetterie le
foot français serait alors en danger si
médias pro et contraint de se retirer la
Ligue devra se tourner vers d'autres
diffuseurs comme Canal+ sans oublier les
Gafa les géants du numérique qui
pourraient vouloir investir comme Amazon
qui a récupéré les droits de
Roland-Garros entre 2021 et 2023
alors on va partir des derniers
événements Virgil cahier c'est vous bien
on a vu la conférence de presse de raï
c'est ce que il a rassuré à votre avis
est-ce qu'il vous a convaincu alors je
pense qu'il a convaincu personne et il a
rassuré personne et je pense que c'était
pas l'exercice il faut pas perdre de vue
que les deux acteurs sont dans une
partie de poker menteur et un
discutablement ce monsieur ores doit
être très fort au poker et donc
l'objectif c'est simplement de jouer sa
partition de jouer son rôle il ne peut
pas dire qu'ils vont arrêter de payer il
ne peut pas dire que tout va bien qu'il
va payer renégocier son contrat alors
renégocier effectivement il va falloir
définir sur quelle base pour l'instant
on n'en sait rien il milite pour une
certaine confidentialité des discussions
puisqu'ils sont rentré dans une logique
de de conciliation
est prête à faire un petit effort ou pas
la Ligue objectivement ne pourra pas
elle ne pourra pas tout simplement parce
que la plupart des clubs ont bien
entendu intégré ces montants dans leur
budget et pour certains clubs pour
beaucoup d'entre eux ils les ont déjà
dépensés donc autant vous dire que la
ligne ne peut pas faire marche arrière
et Media Pro ne peut pas dépenser autant
donc finalement les situations sont
bloquées je ne vois pas comment on va
pouvoir sortir de cette crise Cédric ça
veut dire que la ligne ne peut pas se
passer de média pro elle ne peut pas
lancer un nouvel appel d'offres en
disant finalement ce média pro n'est pas
fini fiable et fragile financièrement on
fait autre chose c'est pas possible ça
si elle peut elle peut repartir sur un
impact d'offres mais encore il faut t-il
que suivre la procédure la procédure
c'est qu'il y a il y a déjà des
garanties actionnées puisque il faut
quand même le rappeler il y a une
garantie même si aujourd'hui tout le
monde a l'air de dire que c'était
évident que cette garantie ne valait
rien mais en tout cas il y en a une il y
a des procédures il y a des retards de
paiement mais il faut juste remettre des
choses dans le contexte aujourd'hui
MédiaPRO a décidé de faire appel à un
conciliateur et donc ça suspend le temps
ça suspend le temps de notamment des
procédures de la LFP pour pouvoir donc
réagir donc en tout cas très clairement
il y a des solutions de sortie de crise
maintenant il faut qu'elle se discute à
deux moi je note juste parce que je suis
pas que fan de coach président d'un
groupe d'études depuis trois ans
et on avait invité justement donc euh
tous les acteurs et à commencer donc par
par MédiaPRO et le président rouresse
bon il a décliné l'invitation donc moi
je suis très étonné de ce point là
puisque pour quelqu'un qui veut de la
conciliation de la concertation la
représentation nationale donc est là
pour ça mérite une commission d'enquête
c'est pourquoi on a attribué ce ses
droits du foot à média pro alors que de
rappeler qu'elle est aujourd'hui donc le
modèle économique voilà le modèle
économique il a un impact nécessairement
sur les clubs amateurs puisqu'on a un
principe inédit de solidarité financière
du sport professionnel envers le sport
amateur c'est un modèle unique et donc
forcément ça va impacter sur le budget
du sport et de toutes les associations
de nos territoires et sans parler la
filière emploi c'est 35000 emplois et il
faut savoir qu'il y a plus de de
recettes matchs quasiment plus c'est à
dire qu'il y a plus d'activités aussi
professionnel pendant les matchs parce
que ne serait-ce que que ça
du droit du foot dans le foot français
il y a tous les clubs mais il y a aussi
en partie les fédérations alors il y a
en partie la fédération mais surtout
essentiellement le modèle oui alors
c'est la taxe buffet c'est l'une taxe de
5% calculée sur l'ensemble des droits TV
qui est reversé donc c'est l'équivalent
cette année puisqu'on a amendé pour
faire en sorte d'augmenter donc ce
fléchage vers le sport 74 millions voilà
tout le monde dépend des droits cette
année c'est 74 millions pour le sport
amateurs c'est c'est au fond on a
l'impression que c'est la chronique d'un
désastre annoncé depuis le début il y a
des problèmes médias pro étaient mal
noté par des agences de notation il
était pas très fiable
800 millions c'est énorme c'est normal
qu'on ne comprennent pas parce que c'est
incompréhensible quelqu'un qui achète
des droits tout le monde était très
sceptique sur le modèle économique il
faut se rappeler quand même que on si on
remet dans le dans le contexte
comme le disait Cédric donc ça remonte à
deux ans c'était 2018 donc là tout le
monde est tombé sur le cul par me donnez
moi l'expression
en voyant que
la plupart des lots donc 80% de la Ligue
1 80% de la Ligue 2 donc à partir de là
tu peux les clubs de foot se frottent
les mains parce que ça veut dire une
augmentation de 70 % de leurs droits
donc tout le monde est content mais tous
les techniciens doutent du modèle le
contrat arrive donc
débute sur cette saison actuelle
Media Pro c'est c'est pas privé de
critiquer canal et bim qui refusait de
payer les derniers droits à cause de la
situation de la covid donc il critiquait
à l'époque on était au mois de mai juin
avant que le championnat ne se termine
en queue en queue de poisson et puis
donc le championnat démarre et au bout
de trois mois de championnat et bien
ceux qui avaient acheté les droits
disent finalement on trouve que ces
droits là ils ont pu la valeur qu'ils
avaient quand on les a acheté donc on a
envie de renégocier à la baisse c'est
incompréhensible ça n'existe pas et
d'autant que pour ceux qui regardent
donc les fans de foot et très rare c'est
c'est cher c'est très cher c'est 30
euros l'abonnement c'est ça c'est
beaucoup alors il y a une chose qui est
d'ailleurs pas très compréhensible dans
l'histoire dans la mesure où les stades
sont fermés que les matchs jouent à huis
clos normalement il devrait y avoir plus
de monde devant la télévision et donc
peut-être plus d'abonnés à l'avenir donc
là c'est une espèce de marchandage que
exerce Media Pro que moi personnellement
je ne comprends pas bien parce que Media
Pro normalement devrait à tout à y
gagner est-ce que les stats soient vides
la recette pour les clubs des des
spectateurs et des pas négligeable mais
c'est pas contrairement au rugby c'est
pas le football ne vit pas des gens qui
sont dans les stades ils vivent des gens
qui sont devant la télévision donc
médias pro je trouve est plutôt assez
mauvais joueur dans cette histoire et
puis il y a une deuxième chose
je ne connais pas le contrat qui lit la
ligue avec Media Pro dans son détail je
ne crois pas qu'il y a une clause qui
prévoit que en cas d'événements
exceptionnel et bien mais il y a pro
puisse renoncer à payer donc là si on
fait et si on fait jouer l'argument
juridique et judiciaire mais il y a
Proust je sais pas là je parle devrait
s'exposer quand même à un avenir qui me
paraît
faramineux sur le plan financier
des amendes
à payer encore plus oui il va y avoir de
la casse
ça c'est sûr c'est ce qui fait peur
maintenant à beaucoup de gens et puis au
pouvoir public aussi parce que ce sont
quelque part des pouvoirs des
pourvoyeurs aussi de de de
du financement du sport mais il va y
avoir la casse sociale il va l'avoir
elle casse financière bien entendu pour
Media Pro qui perd en crédibilité ça
tous les jours donc il faut savoir
qu'ils ont une activité internationale
aussi et également ça ne rassure pas les
abonnés parce qu'il faut quand même
parler d'eux ils sont les supporters
sont assignés à résidence à cause donc
du covid et de cette restriction de
jauge donc effectivement on comprend pas
trop en quoi ça remet en question le
modèle économique de ce point de vue là
ça ne leur remet pas en question après
il y a le sujet aussi du piratage
effectivement il faut ce serait
intéressant de voir quel est
la jauge de pirate à l'insu de leur
plein graisses j'ai envie de dire parce
qu'il y a un problème de rationalisation
de l'offre on ne comprend plus rien
alors qu'est-ce qui va se passer si
média Pro ne peut plus payer où est-on
voir le foot est-ce qu'il peut y avoir
un repreneur ou pas il y aura forcément
repreneur cercle la Ligue 1 ne restera
pas sans diffusion ça c'est
innovisageable ouf pourrait-on dire
effectivement vous pourrez voir vos
clubs préférés en revanche effectivement
comme ça a été dit auparavant il y a
toute une procédure qui va falloir
suivre et ça ça va être long ça risque
d'être long et le préjudice va être
probablement colossal tout le monde est
perdant dans cette affaire en fait il y
a que déperdant le seul qui pourrait
être gagnant dans cette dans cette
histoire ce serait le diffuseur qui va
pouvoir récupérer un contrat à la casse
pour
Canal+ même pas probablement pas Canal+
c'est pas une chaîne de sport ils ont
déjà un lot qui leur assure de belles
affiches le seul lot qui pourrait les
intéresser c'est le match du dimanche
soir mais en revanche les 80% de la
Ligue 1 ça les intéresse pas après ça
peut être des chaînes des chaînes
sportives un BeIn Sport éventuellement
ou un Altice au travers des RMC Sport
mais c'est pas la tendance puisque ils
sont en train de se désengager donc il
reste beaucoup d'acteurs et quand on est
dans une logique de marché où il y a de
l'offre mais finalement peu d'acheteurs
souvent les prix vont à la baisse et les
Gafa Amazon
c'est un sujet en fait ce dont on parle
là c'est l'appel d'offres tout le monde
effectivement avec les yeux pris qui
brillent parce que
la première partie je dirais de
l'objectif de la mission d'ailleurs de
Didier Kyo c'était les revenus et des
présidents de club et je veux dire de
l'AFP c'est avant tout de capter des
revenus supplémentaires pour que ça
ruisselle en suite mais le deuxième
objectif ça reste quand même
l'exposition et là de ce côté-là c'est
un c'était quand même un échec d'une
part parce que effectivement c'est très
compliqué maintenant de comprendre
l'offre télévision visuelle mais en plus
j'ai envie de dire c'est que je répète
ça le pouvoir d'achat 80 à 100 euros
pour suivre son club lorsqu'il est je
dirais au niveau européen aussi donc je
pense que il va falloir aussi s'il y a
je dirais un second appel d'offres de
bien réfléchir à la quantité aux
qualités également parce que ça reste du
spectacle du spectacle vivant et il faut
être très attentif à ça à ce qu'ils
soient très bien exposé aussi
à votre question au Gafa mais vous
rendez compte ceci n'est Gafa mettent la
main sur le football ça veut dire que
notre vie est entre les mains des Gafa
il contrôle tout aujourd'hui c'est à
dire que y compris le contrôle serait
dans la main des géants du monde
c'est déjà le cas dans dans certaines
ligues professionnelles de football
notamment en Angleterre ou Amazon a
toute une partie des droits et puis il
faut voir aussi l'évolution de la
consommation du sport dans les médias
c'est un élément qui est déterminant
dans cette affaire et c'est probablement
la raison de de l'attitude de la posture
de médias pro aujourd'hui parce que
qu'est-ce qu'a changé depuis le mois de
juillet le mois de juillet ils étaient
ravis défendaient la Ligue 1 ils
disaient que c'était un très beau
produit et ils ont payé en temps et en
heure leur première échéance et là en
l'espace de trois mois le covid on l'a
connu on l'avait connu avant et là en
l'espace de trois mois d'un seul coup
latitude a complètement changé qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé
quels sont les éléments qui ont fait
qu'ils ont changé leur posture et
qu'aujourd'hui ils négocie à la baisse
ce contrat qu'il considérait comme
extrêmement vraiment intéressant pour
terminer est-ce qui le scénario
catastrophe qui a aucun repreneur est-ce
que ça il est exclu non il y a une
valeur du championnat après
effectivement la question de savoir
quelle est la dépréciation de cette
valeur compte tenu de de cette crise et
de ce litige moi je voudrais juste dire
parce que j'avais pas terminé
effectivement sur le sur les gafam je
pense que le gafam et Amazon peut être
justement une réponse à cette à ces
usage qui ont changé et peut être
justement donc un moyen de diversifier
donc la consommation du spectacle
sportif et justement un nouveau
challenger pour pouvoir donc avoir un
public le plus large aussi dans la
consommation du sport qui a totalement
changé ce feuilleton n'est pas terminé
merci de nous l'avoir décrypté j'y vois
beaucoup plus clair merci beaucoup non
c'est c'est intéressant c'est très
politique aussi ça ça nous concerne tous
merci beaucoup oui frère d'être passé
par ce plateau les grands entretiens de
LCP se la retrouver sur la chaîne
Youtube de LCP ainsi que sur LCP.fr
c'est passionnant merci messieurs très
belle soirée et à demain
[Musique]